- Le problème c'est que je peux même pas dire si t'as gagné.
- Je suis même pas sûr
Et un espadon dédé de la didule
le dindon c'est du dédé fit son dada qui le garda.
- T'as gagné.
- Pas mal hein ?
Bravo ! Bien joué !
- Bonjour Seb, je suis très heureux
de t'accueillir dans mon atelier.
Est-ce que ça te va
si je présente cette rencontre comme celle
d'un jeune homme
qui est déjà un vieux YouTubeur
avec un homme un peu plus vieux
qui, lui, est un jeune YouTubeur ?
- Ça me va très très bien.
On était tous très très contents
quand on t'a vu arriver. On se disait
mais... c'est sa place, c'est fait pour lui,
c'est évident.
- Eh bien,
merci de m'accueillir dans la bande.
Merci beaucoup.
On va commencer par une petite,
une petite bio express.
Toi, tu as commencé très jeune, à l'âge
de quatorze ans,
par faire des vidéos sur les jeux vidéos.
Comment t'as eu cette idée !?
Qu'est-ce qui te motivait à l'époque ?
- En fait, il y a deux vrais
débuts. Il y avait une espèce
de mode, fut un temps quand j'étais
au collège,
des sketchs audios.
C'est un truc qui a un petit peu disparu
maintenant, avec les vidéos, tout ça.
Et c'était les premiers téléphones portables.
Et dessus, on avait de la place
pour un ou deux sketchs audios.
Et un jour, j'avais piqué
la caméra de ma mère, la petite compact.
Et la particularité de cette caméra
c'est qu'elle ne faisait pas de son.
Et ce qui était génial,
je me disais mais c'est génial
moi j'ai du son où il n'y a pas d'image,
donc je vais essayer de refaire ces sketchs
pour qu'avec mes amis on ait un ensemble.
Et c'est comme ça
que j'ai commencé par faire un blog où
j'essayais de reproduire un peu
comme les Tiktok d'aujourd'hui,
je reparlais par-dessus les comédiens
et du coup, j'ai commencé comme ça.
J'ai un peu perdu ce truc, mais ce truc là m'a donné le goût de me dire "Ok
j'ai compris que c'est
un truc qui me plaît de faire ça".
La deuxième phase,
c'est, on est une bande de copains
et on découvre un logiciel de montage
et on aime bien trifouiller un petit peu
ces choses qui nous amusent, d'aller chercher.
Et on se rend compte
on est très jeunes,
on a quatorze ans,
que quand on découpe une séquence
et qu'on s'amuse à faire n'importe
quoi avec, juste on fait dire
une phrase à quelqu'un
qui veut dire autre chose,
c'est quelque chose d'hilarant à l'âge qu'on avait.
Et on crée une chaîne en commun,
on détourne des discours, etc.
Et au fil du temps, en fait,
j'ai fini par être le seul qui faisait ça.
Même si à la base
on était cinq sur
ma première chaîne YouTube.
- Et puis, très vite,
tu vas commencer à t'intéresser à la musique
et à commenter des vidéos.
Et là, t'as plutôt la dent dure.
- Ouais, c'était une petite période petit c*n,
je peux dire un petit c*n !?
- Oui, tu peux !
- C'était totalement ce que j'étais.
- Ça m'est arrivé aussi.
- En fait, quand il y a eu aussi l'émergence
de tous les gens
sur Internet, déjà YouTubeur
n'existe pas à ce moment où je fais ça.
Et personne ne parlait
des clips de musique.
Or, je passais beaucoup de temps
avec mes amis des fois à voir des clips
et à faire des blagues dessus.
Je me suis dit je peux faire la même chose
avec une caméra.
- T'es un peu un troll à l'époque.
- Ouais, encore un peu maintenant.
- Tu as eu des retours d'ailleurs de ceux que tu clashais un peu !?
- Ouais, ouais. À l'époque,
la plupart des gens le prenaient bien.
- C'était vraiment pour rire
ou parfois il y avait vraiment
des choses que tu détestais
ou que tu trouvais ridicules !?
- Non, mais en fait, moi
je conçois un peu l'humour.
Je le trouve toujours efficace
s'il est un peu sous couvert
d'une petite part de vérité.
- Est-ce que tu t'es moqué de moi ?
- Je me suis jamais moqué de toi.
Je t'ai déjà dédicacé.
J'ai fait une vidéo
qui s'appelle L'histoire du rap
et je sais que dedans j'ai
une petite télé qui est à côté de moi
et à un moment donné,
je fais apparaître un ami à moi.
- Elle est géniale d'ailleurs cette vidéo
et toutes les vidéos que tu as faites
sur l'histoire de la musique.
A chaque fois, cette dimension historique
est vraiment vraiment géniale.
- Et bien c'est gentil.
- Tu te sens bien toi sur Youtube !?
- Je me sens bien.
Mais j'ai l'impression
d'y trouver un espèce de...
de plafond de verre.
J'ai l'impression d'y voir
une limite et c'est
un truc qui peut-être est un peu démotivant.
J'ai du mal aujourd'hui à voir
où est la prochaine étape.
Là où, en fait, si je veux faire un truc
encore plus produit,
finalement,
je vais peut-être directement faire un documentaire
et peut-être viser les plateformes ou
la télévision ou autre chose.
- C'est arrivé.
Et si je veux faire un truc plus détente,
je pourrais très bien
lancer un live sur Twitch.
- Mais en même temps,
c'est ce qui est génial aujourd'hui.
C'est-à-dire qu'on a à notre disposition
ces différents supports.
Ce que j'aime, c'est diffuser
de la connaissance.
Donc, quand je vois un nouvel outil
et comment je peux utiliser cet outil
pour diffuser de la connaissance,
je pense que pour toi, ça doit être un peu pareil.
- Ouais.
Et puis en fait, aujourd'hui,
ce qui est génial,
c'est qu'on a un espèce de choix.
- Complètement.
On a cette possibilité.
C'est un truc complètement
dingue. Je ne veux pas jouer
le dinosaure, mais
moi, en 1981,
quand les radios libres ont vu le jour,
j'avais seize ans.
Mais ça a été un truc complètement dingue !
Et je me suis retrouvé moi à seize ans,
quasiment dès le début,
je me souviens,
c'était un mois de novembre,
un vendredi soir, devant un micro, et c'était
une espèce de forme de liberté
d'expression extraordinaire.
- Du coup, t'es passé à la télévision
par la radio ?
Oui, moi, au début, je voulais faire
de la radio, je n'aimais pas la télévision
et j'avais eu
un prof qui disait "Jamy Gourmaud, jamais
il fera de télévision de sa vie".
Je ne donnerai pas le nom du prof.
- Nous aujourd'hui, avec Internet,
là où on fait
le contraste, c'est qu'on peut s'exprimer
de toutes les manières, sur toutes
les façons différentes de le faire.
Là où, à une époque, en fait,
c'était complètement très, très fermé quoi.
- Bah c'était fermé
et quand on voulait justement
pouvoir s'exprimer à travers un média
comme la télévision, il fallait trouver
un concept qui soit suffisamment fort.
Quand on est allé avec Fred
vendre entre guillemets
ce projet...
il nous coulait dans les veines !
Et on était,
je crois, très convaincants
parce qu'on aimait
ce dont on parlait avant de l'avoir fait.
Je voudrais qu'on parle de ta chaîne.
Toi aujourd'hui,
tu te consacres essentiellement
à la musique, à l'histoire de la musique.
Comment tu bosses ?
- Je n'ai pas vraiment
de schéma type où je me dis OK, c'est ça, ça,
ça je jette.
J'essaye de me dire qu'est-ce qui m'intéresserait, moi, de regarder
et jusqu'où
ça peut aller dans cette histoire là.
- Est-ce que tu aurais
des conseils d'un expert de YouTube
à donner à un jeune YouTubeur ?
Tu vois à qui je pense.
- Le vrai conseil,
c'est celui un petit peu bateau.
Être fier de ce que tu fais, être content de ce que tu donnes
parce qu'il ne faut pas oublier
que c'est figé dans le temps.
Voilà quoi.
- Je ne sais pas si t'as vu sur le bar,
j'ai réuni quelques objets.
- Si, si !
Ce sont des objets
qui doivent t'inspirer un petit peu
parce qu'ils sont très liés
à ton expérience.
- C'est vrai.
- Il y a un parachute.
Qu'est-ce qui t'inspire ce parachute ?
- Le parachute il m'évoque l'une
des dernières expériences un peu,
un peu loufoques
que j'ai pu faire cet été.
Je passe un diplôme,
je deviens parachutiste
pour pouvoir sauter seul.
J'ai beaucoup d'équipement, j'ai du son,
mon retour voix. Et le but,
c'est d'avoir quelque chose
d'adapter à une instrumentale.
Du coup, sur laquelle moi je vais rapper tout en tombant sachant que c'est 50 m/s quand la vitesse se stabilise,
donc 200 km/h.
Parti de rien
j'aimerais tout faire, plus lourd que toi
mais j'suis tout frêle
j'rends pas les coups frère
j'm'en bats les co**lles d'ailleurs
pourquoi t'écoutes ?
- C'est complètement dingue ! T'as fait
combien de sauts au total ?
- Au total, j'en ai fait 17.
17 sauts pour le résultat qu'on voit.
C'est aussi une expérience,
humaine et sportive
qui est très, très enrichissante, qui
rend fier, bizarrement.
- Mais c'est ce que tu disais
tout à l'heure être fier de soi.
- Ouais, ça me boost la confiance, on va dire.
- On va passer un deuxième objet
le vinyle.
- Ouais.
qui vient de sortir. Ça
du coup, c'est un projet sur lequel j'ai
bossé. Pareil aussi,
c'est ces choses dans le temps.
Pendant deux ans.
Donc, ouais c'est un exercice qui m'a piqué.
Et donc, du coup,
j'ai pris le temps et je me suis dit
je veux pas.
Je pourrais en deux semaines essayer
d'écrire, faire un truc et sortir un
projet.
Je me suis dit non, je prends mon temps.
Et puis voilà, j'en suis super fier.
- Mais c'est quelque chose que tu as gardé
secret quand même un peu.
- Ouais, en tout cas, aux yeux du public oui.
c'est un truc où, en fait,
les gens s'en doutaient parce que
ceux qui me suivaient, mais
qui aimaient un peu fouiller,
ils voyaient que je faisais des morceaux de temps en temps.
J'en sortais
même sur des chaines secondaires.
J'ai toujours fait ça un peu secrètement.
-  En loucedé, comme ça.
-Voilà, en fait
je voulais faire de la musique
et je ne voulais pas que mon image empiète
sur le fait de m'amuser sur le côté.
Et quand on fait du rap, il y a un truc
qui n'est pas facile, bon il y a écrire déjà,
et puis il y a ensuite la prononciation.
- Oui.
Alors derrière nous,
sur le petit établi,
il y a quelques petites phrases
qui sont extraites
d'un bouquin,
un bouquin, de virelangue. Donc des virelangues
ce sont des phrases
qui sont difficiles à prononcer
que souvent,
les comédiens utilisent. Moi-même
il m'arrive de temps en temps
de me répéter des choses
le matin pour articuler
et pour avoir une bonne diction.
On va se déplacer, on va laller vers l'établi
et puis on va faire une petite battle.
- Vas-y, let's go !
- Allez hop, hop !
- Franchement c'est pas mal.
- C'est bon. Allez, à toi de tirer.
- Ouais mais j'ai un peu plus eu le temps, c'est pour ça
Allez
1, 2, 3
- Ouh !
ça y est, j'ai perdu.
Alors ça, je pense en plus que c'est
un extrait d'une chanson de Boby Lapointe.
- Ah ouais ?
- Ouais.
Ah !
On est toujours à deux.
- J'ai aucune idée des points.
- 2-2 ?
OK, c'est quelqu'un qui nous fait
signe, qui nous fait ça.
Ça veut dire "2-2" en fait.
- Ou alors, il est très heureux.
- Le problème, c'est que je peux pas dire si tu t'es trompé.
- Je suis même pas sûr, j'en ai aucune idée.
- Alors je vais essayer.
- Pareil, je n'ai aucune idée si...
- Bon, t'as gagné.
- Ouais, j'ai un point.
- Woaaaaah...
Il est dur.
il est très très dur. Il est très très dur celui-là.
- T'as été meilleur que moi.
- Ah, je connaissais une chanson comme ça
qu'on chantait mômes. On chantait  " Et un espadon
à Dédé donna dudule, d'un don si doux Dédé fit son dada qu'il garda.
Le criquet de la crique,
cri son cri cru et critique car il craint
que l'escroc ne le craque et ne le croque.
- T'as gagné !
- Pas mal hein ?
- T'as gagné, t'as gagné.
Bravo, bien joué !
- Alors sur le bar,
il y a également un chapeau, une paire
de jumelles, un kangourou arboricole.
Ça, c'est une référence à un truc
complètement dingue que tu as fait.
C'est carrément une expédition
dans la forêt primaire en Papouasie,
Papouasie occidentale.
- Oui, on a monté une expédition
et on était une petite dizaine
avec une équipe de spéléologues
qui, eux, sont spécialisés
dans la cartographie, c'est-à-dire
explorer des souterrains,
cartographier les zones.
Et il y avait une zone du globe,
justement en Papouasie occidentale,
qui n'est pas encore explorée
dans son intérieur.
Et il y a pas mal d'endroits en extérieur
qui sont aussi assez nouveaux.
Du coup,
le but de cette expédition, c'était
d'aller explorer cet endroit là.
Et après aussi, on a essayé de construire
tout un récit, tout un voyage autour de cette expédition.
On est allé rencontrer les Papous
dans un village.
On a fait une petite partie,
un petit dix jours en mer
par les Raja Ampat, on a exploré les fonds marins.
- Tu parles de voyage mais ce qu'il
faut bien comprendre quand même,
c'est que, c'est une expédition,
tu accompagnes des scientifiques,
ça se passe en Papouasie occidentale,
ce n'est pas une balade de santé.
Là, on part, tu pars à l'aventure,
mais l'aventure avec un grand A,
ce sont des conditions vraiment extrêmes.
- Bien sûr.
Surtout que,
c'est un climat qui est tropical.
On ne peut plus tropical.
C'est, là où on était, l'une
des dernières
grosses forêts tropicales
vraiment quasi intactes,
ce qui fait de plus en plus rare,
malheureusement.
Donc, du coup, l'humidité à fond,
c'est des conditions qui sont, mine
de rien, pas du tout adaptées à l'homme.
Donc,
on doit s'adapter en conséquence à ça.
Et c'est plus l'espèce d'acclimatation
de tout cet environnement là
qui rend les choses difficiles.
- Il y a un taux d'humidité
qui doit être de l'ordre de 95%.
Je crois que ça va jusqu'à 97%.
- Ouais, ça doit être un truc comme ça.
Pour
qu'on ait une idée, un petit peu
des conditions dans lesquelles
tu t'es trouvé.
Moi il m'est arrivé de faire
ce genre de choses, mais plutôt en Guyane,
en forêt, en forêt tropicale.
Je me souviens, j'avais une montre,
j'avais un bracelet en cuir,
j'avais des moisissures sur le bracelet.
- Les chaussures, les semelles.
Je sais que là, je pense que
je vais devoir refaire mon passeport.
Il était juste
dans un film plastique, dans
mon sac à dos et il s'est ouvert.
Donc, du coup,
j'ai eu toutes les pages qui se sont collées.
Tout déteint. Et c'est très, très humide.
- C'est très désagréable. Il y a des bêtes aussi.
- Il y a des bestioles évidemment.
On est, on est dans un endroit où on est
un peu sur leur territoire.
- Envie de recommencer ?
- Ouais. J'ai
la prochaine expédition.
- Est-ce que c'est indiscret de te demander où ?
- Normalement ce serait le Kirghiztan.
- Ouais.
- Je sais pas
si... je pense que je vais te le pitcher
hors caméra par curiosité.
- D'accord, ok.
Est-ce qu'il y a des
des zones comme ça que
tu aimerais visiter ?
- Il y en a beaucoup.
Il y en a beaucoup.
Il y en a une qui m'effraie un petit peu
plus que le reste.
C'est le grand froid.
- Oui.
- J'adorerais.
J'adorerais
ne serait-ce qu'expérimenter déjà.
Je n'ai jamais eu
l'occasion d'aller et je dis même
jamais eu l'occasion de ressentir,
je sais pas, un -30°C.
Qu'est-ce que ça doit faire ?
- Alors moi j'ai dormi par -35°C.
- Alors ?
- C'est très, très étonnant parce que
tu te glisses dans ton sac de couchage
tu remontes la fermeture jusqu'en haut
et le matin
quand tu te réveilles,
tu as de la glace sur tes sourcils
autour des moustaches et il fait
grosso modo dans la tente
entre -10°C et -14°C.
Donc, c'est comme si tu passais la nuit
dans un congélateur.
Mais quand tu te lèves la nuit
pour aller faire pipi dehors.
C'est un truc de dingue.
- Ohlala...
-C'est un truc de dingue.
- Le regret de ne pas y avoir pensé
plus tôt.
- Mais c'est vachement intéressant
ce que tu dis
parce que moi, l'un de mes rêves, c'est
d'aller au pôle Nord
ou au pôle Sud.
C'est un truc... je veux un jour dans ma vie
franchir l'un de ces deux points.
Voilà,
on pourrait peut-être le faire ensemble.
- On pourrait le faire ensemble,
tout à fait.
- C'est une bonne idée.
- À fond.
- Bah écoute.
- C'est signé !
- On va y réfléchir.
- C'est vrai.
- Allez un dernier truc.
Il y a une photo du Dalaï-lama.
Ça, c'est un truc complètement dingue.
Tu as rencontré le Dalaï-lama !
- Je me suis rendu en Inde pour réaliser
une interview avec des amis à moi.
Du coup, on a tout un périple
pour arriver là où il est en exil
aujourd'hui dans le nord de l'Inde.
- Dharamsala oui
- Dharamsala, c'est ça.
Et donc, du coup, expérience
aussi fascinante qu'enrichissante que...
j'ai tellement appris dans ce truc
sans pouvoir palper
ce qui venait de m'arriver. En fait moi
j'en retiens tellement, genre
plus de tous le voyage
et de tout ce qu'on y a vécu, ce qu'on
y a appris la manière
dont on vit les choses.
Moi il y a plein de choses qui sont très étonnantes pour moi.
Quand on va là-bas,
on allait visiter son temple,
on allait visiter...
Il y a beaucoup, beaucoup d'adeptes qui
s'y déplacent, qui viennent le voir aussi.
Et je sais qu'avant l'interview,
il avait une représentation.
C'est aussi impressionnant de voir ça.
Il prône tellement la paix
et il est tellement...
Mais il est tellement important
qu'il est obligé pour quelqu'un qui prône
la paix d'être entouré de gardes armés.
- Ah oui.
- J'étais là, en mode... tu sais c'est
tous ces trucs là où tu te dis
"mais on est dans un film,
tout me paraît irréel".
- On arrive au terme de cet entretien,
de cette rencontre.
Alors, il y a une petite coutume ici.
C'est que je quitte l'atelier le premier
et je laisse mon invité seul
avec la caméra et je te laisse me poser
la dernière question.
Je m'en vais pour que tu n'aies aucun
scrupule à me la poser et j'y répondrai
ensuite, je la découvrirai
et y répondrai sur les réseaux.
- Alors,
Jamy, moi j'ai une question
et pense que c'est une question
que beaucoup de gens vont se poser.
Tu es quelqu'un qui as exploré beaucoup de choses,
tu es quelqu'un qui a appris beaucoup de choses.
Forcément,
il y a peut-être une, deux ou trois,
peut-être plus de choses qui toi te marquent
et te reviennent à l'esprit.
Si tu pouvais nous raconter à nous tous
un truc qui t'a marqué dans ta vie
après avoir vécu autant de choses.
Qu'est-ce que tu pourrais bien nous
raconter dans tes anecdotes personnelles ?
Merci à toutes et à tous d'avoir suivi
cette vidéo.
J'espère que vous avez apprécié
d'en savoir un peu plus sur Seb.
On vous a parlé de pas mal de ces projets.
Nous avons mis les liens en description.
Indiquez-moi également
en commentaire le nom des personnes
que vous aimeriez voir dans cet atelier.
La semaine prochaine
je reçois dans Bien Reçu
un personnage mythique.
Alors, n'hésitez pas à vous
abonner pour ne pas le louper.